[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hier soir Vladimir Poutine ordonne à ses
troupes d'entrer dans l'est de l'Ukraine
deux territoires séparatistes qu'il
considère désormais indépendant j'ai vu
passer des photos d'Emmanuel Macron pas
rasé la tête entre les mains tout ça
très artistique je pense que ça n'est
pas sérieux de faire de la communication
sur ces sujets-là nous exigeons deux
l'arrêt immédiat des opérations
militaires autrement toute la
responsabilité de la poursuite de
l'effusion de sang reposera totalement
sur la conscience du régime ukrainien
est immédiate
la décision de la Russie est une
violation de l'intégrité territoriale et
de la souveraineté de l'Ukraine nous
sommes sur notre propre terre nous
n'avons peur de rien ni de personne nous
ne devons rien à personne et nous ne
donnerons rien
annonce une série de sanctions
économiques contre la Russie la France
portera maintenant la voix à la fois de
la poursuite du dialogue du soutien
indéfectible au peuple ukrainien et
celle des sanctions nous avons convenu
de cibler 27 individus et entités qui
jouent un rôle pour miner ou pour
menacer l'intégrité territoriale et
l'indépendance de l'Ukraine il y aura
aussi des sanctions financières à
l'égard de l'Etat russe par des
dispositifs concernant des banques et
pas concernant aussi le dispositif de
financement de l'État russe à la fois
par des sanctions européennes et des
sanctions américaines
de quoi parle-t-il aucune sanction n'a
jamais avec les Russes pourquoi cette
fois-ci mieux qu'une autre tout le monde
sait que c'est pas vrai donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a une façon d'accepter que
la frontière soit violée
d'un peu de dignité dans cette affaire
ses attaques sont purement politiciennes
combien y a-t-il de Français qui
travaillent pour des entreprises russes
les républicains cette partie de
Monsieur Fillon qui complice de Monsieur
Poutine
de la France pendant 5 ans plusieurs
fois qui connaît à mon avis à peu près
tous les secrets de la France qui vend
aujourd'hui son carnet d'adresses ces
informations à Vladimir Poutine c'est
choquant
Emmanuel Macron a désavoué ce mardi
2022 et cela fait beaucoup parler parce
qu'il s'agit d'un palindrome une date
qui peut se lire dans les deux sens mais
aussi à l'envers parce qu'en plus c'est
un ambigramme le fait d'accorder son
parrainage à un candidat n'est pas
automatiquement synonyme de sout
politique c'est aussi un acte
démocratique j'ai quasiment arrêté ma
campagne vous imaginez tout de même on
est à 50 jours de l'élection
présidentielle je suis obligé d'arrêter
ma campagne pour me consacrer
exclusivement à cette recherche de
parrainage
on est précisé en pleine action pour
faire en sorte que nous voyons les 500
parrainage c'est très difficile ça
nécessite beaucoup de travail c'est un
peu comme si j'allais voir ma sœur en
faisant le beau et que je lui demande un
service à sa même lui avoir demandé des
nouvelles de sa santé je peux vous dire
que je passerai de orbitesse
chérie raisonnablement parce que il faut
na bosser on continue à bosser on
continue à démarcher si ça aboutit au
fait qu'il y a des gens qui sont
éliminés c'est c'est désastreux
c'est parce qu'ils sont pas proches du
terrain je décrypte bien ce que vous
voulez dire